the north las vegas police department  partnering with new beginnings  ministries to get students ready for the  school year today they gave out new  shoes backpacks and general school  supplies senior pastor bobby smith says  the event was a great way to make sure  students feel confident when entering  the classroom  we notice right away is when we give  them to them they're absolutely happy  and we know that it builds confidence  because now they get to fit in and some  people come from different financial  demographics so we want to put everybody  on the same playing field so they get to  go to school regardless of their  financial you know demographic and look  like everybody else  barbers and stylists were on site giving  free haircuts and braids as well